this is a production of Cornell
University
hello my name is Celine deceases and
today I will be talking to you about the
mechanisms behind negative priming of
soil organic carbon by pyrogenic organic
matter so first we're going to start off
with the why we're really changing
scales and topics here from our last
talk or getting a lot smaller and so why
are we concerned about these
interactions and the number one why is
that pyrogenic organic matter is
everywhere so in recent history it's
been touted as this exciting new
agricultural amendment this magic bullet
but it's also been added to our soil for
hundreds of years for thousands of years
throughout human history through cook
fires burn pits and more importantly
it's been added to the soil through
natural events like forest fires
lightning strikes for hundreds of
thousands of years so this stuff is
ubiquitous in soils and we now know that
it has a profound it has profound
interactions between itself and the soil
organic carbon that's already there so
it's impacting the soil organic carbon
and in recent work in our lab we have
found some it's been found that this
could have long-term implications for
carbon storage so this is all very
exciting the carbon is there is
interacting with the carbon that we know
and care about and today we're going to
kind of pull apart these interactions
and brings break them down to a
mechanistic level so priming is a word
I'm going to be using one today and it's
used differently throughout the
literature but in relation to my work
that pile priming of soil organic carbon
by PI om is basically describing a
change in mineralization rate so when
you add pi om to soil organic carbon it
might increase the mineralization rate
that would be positive priming or it may
decrease the mineralization rate which
be negative priming and today we're all
we're only going to talk about negative
priming because this is what I've found
in my research and this is also kind of
what's exciting in terms of long-term
carbon storage
so this is a list of proposed mechanisms
of negative priming kind of gotten from
current literature surrounding this work
and we're going to walk through them one
by one and these little icons these
colorful icons on the right are going to
repeat throughout the presentation today
so you'll hear these words a lot you'll
see these colors when you see them in
the upper right of the screen that kind
of means that whatever i'm talking about
is related to that kind of them so this
is our baseline situation over here we
have soil microbes they're eating soil
carbon they're aspiring co2 so for their
first negative mechan- priming mechanism
we have inhibition of nutrient mining
and what's happening here is when you
add the pile em it basically creates a
nutrient source for these microbes so
instead of getting their nutrients from
the soil and aspiring that carbon is
they're going to get the nutrients from
the pile em and that will decrease their
soil respiration so a carbon respiration
so next we have toxicity so this is
pretty simple maybe you're adding the
pile em and it's killing the microbe so
it's reducing their respiration alright
next substrate switching so we're adding
a new substrate that some microbes might
find more tasty and so they're not going
to respire as much soil carbon they're
going to respire trial carbon substrate
dilution so this is kind of a little bit
of the substrate switching and also a
physical die we shun of the soil organic
carbon so basically the pilum addition
is making it harder so those microbes to
get at their tasty soil carbon SOC
sorption so pi om has a really high kind
of absorptive potential it has high
surface area charge and so what may be
happening is that the do see in the soil
or in the soil carbon in general is
being sorbed onto the surface of the
char and this is protecting it from
being mineralized by microbes and then
microbial signal structure so this is
something I'm not really going to touch
on today because I haven't worked with
it at all we're doing some of that in
our labs but it's exciting stuff and
break it down to its simplest form
essentially perhaps ty om
is creating a barrier between the
communication of microbes say one of
them is saying hey there's a bunch of
tasty food over here and the pile em is
blocking that from getting to their
fellow microbes so it's going to reduce
the amount that they were aspiring that
carbon and then the last one is kind of
facilitated aggregation in that when you
add PI om perhaps it's increasing the
ability of that soil to make aggregates
and cause physical protection so these
are kind of the mechanisms that are in
the literature right now and that will
be kind of talking about today so
overall my overarching question is which
mechanisms are responsible of that big
list that we just talked about and today
I'm going to break this into a couple
different questions and topics first
we're going to talk about the dilution
mechanism followed by substrate
switching toxicity and then we're going
to see kind of what's left after that
and how might you parse that out once
we've gotten rid of a couple of these
and so our hypotheses as I was
mentioning we know that PI om is very
absorptive so we're thinking that
sorption is a really important mechanism
but we also know that there's probably
more than one going on and so we're
going at that with this approach kind of
keeping an open mind throughout this
mechanistic study so to look at the
dilution experiment I set up an
experiment where I'm basically trying to
simulate the dilution effect with other
inert media so I'm adding so I'm adding
pile em and then I'm adding these
different media and the same volume
equivalent so I've added perlite courts
and and also a carbon with soil version
of the soil and I'm using in this
experiment i use mardan topsoil from
Mount Pleasant that's about five percent
carbon and I'm pH adjusting the charge
that is equals that of the soils and I'm
also adding nutrients that kind of
overwhelm any nutrient effects that you
would get from adding the char so this
experiment is really targeting the
mechanisms of dilution but also
substrate switching and because of the
way that we've created the experiment
were able to cross off
so we can get rid of nutrient mining
because we're adding more nutrients than
the microbes could ever really need or
that they could get from that extra char
we're also able to cross off ph effects
because we're at ph adjusting the chart
that it equals out of the soil and then
also this is a pretty short scale of
incubation it's only about 30 days and
so we can kind of cross that aggregation
because that's not quite enough time to
really facilitate those type of
interactions in the foil so this slide
is kind of walking through my general
method of investigation this is
simplified we could be like two years of
my life in web site so um so what we did
is I grew I could possibly labeled
willow biomass this has a really super
high 13 c label and then we're creating
piyo em out of this biomass so for this
experiment i'm using a 450 degree char
and then we're adding that char to the
soil and also our other amendments or
their treatments we're wetting these and
then we're monitoring their respiration
over time and we monitor the restoration
using this fancy machine on the seventh
floor of the Picaro and essentially what
this thing spits out is a ppm co2
respired per day and also an isotope
value that corresponds with that co2 so
with those two numbers were able to
throw a little bit of algebra at it and
basically determine how much of that
soil how much of that respiration is
coming from the soil and how much is
coming from the char and through that
calculation we're able to determine
priming so these are some results from
that first experiment so we can see
first I'm going to explain this chart
actually because I'm going to be using
these units a lot today so on the y axis
we have cumulative soil c respired
divided by the initial soil in the jar
so this is normalizing every treatment
based on the amount of carbon that they
started with and it's also cumulative so
it's adding the amount of soil carbon
respired day by day so we see here is
the black line is the control so that's
just the soil we've added nothing to it
and in this particular experiment we
experienced negative priming for all of
our treatments
so even just adding sands completely
inert really low surface area media we
had some negative climbing with that but
we can also see that the perlite may be
a little more surface area more negative
priming followed by this ash sub soil
contains clay probably a lot more
interaction going on with that media and
then finally we have the most negative
priming with our PI om edition and so
what we can say about the aleutian is
that perhaps the dilution effect can be
explained by this difference between the
control in the sand or even the control
in the pot and the in the perlite but
this isn't completely compensating for
the amount of negative priming that we
have from our char and so this is
another way to look at this data so this
is you know the same treatment but
instead of cumulative it's looking at
daily soil carbon respiration and so you
can see that most of this effect most of
this negative priming is happening
rather quickly within the first five
days and also on this chart I've added
the respiration of the char itself you
can see that this has it's pretty
negligible compared to the soil carbon
that's being inspired and finally what
I've done is I've taken each treatment
away from the control so that we can
really have a look at the magnitude of
priming that's going on so the control
doesn't exist in this experiment because
it's Bureau that's what this line is
right here and what we can see is we can
see this increasing negative priming
kind of weird language when less is more
but we can see that yes we have
significant negative priming with this
pi om treatment and up here is the
respired char and so we can also see
that the restoration of the char
definitely can't compensate for the
amount of negative priming that we have
of soil carbon respiration so overall
from that experiment what we can say is
that dilution definitely isn't the only
story neither its substrate substrate
switching but we're going to get back to
that but both are definitely having an
effect they're exerting negative priming
and this is kind of showing us of all
this negative priming exerted by the
chart
me this much about about this much at
this point can be described by this
dilution effect and this much by
substrate switching so we still have
this huge part of the pie that's
unexplained mechanistically so far ok so
now moving on we're going to target
substrate switching as well as soil
organic carbon sorption and so the next
questions to get at these new mechanisms
now that we've kind of crossed off
dilution is how can you be term oh and
also toxicity so that's an important one
so first for toxicity how can we
determine that the char we're applying
is not just killing these microbes and
that's what's causing these interesting
effects next can we make a better case
for refuting the substrate switching
that might be happening and finally if
sorption is this driving mechanism kind
of does it have an end point is there a
smaller amount of char we could add that
wouldn't have this exciting negative
fremming so to ask the answer these
questions I designed an application rate
experiment and it's really simple just
adding kind of different concentrations
of char to the same soil that I use in
my last experiment so we're adding point
5 12 and a half five and ten milligrams
per gram char to the dry soil that same
size percent carbon soil and we're
trying to see if there's an ideal
application rate for negative priming
and also if negative priming doesn't
exist at all over application rate
because maybe all the absorption sites
of the char totally used up and so other
kind of other factors are over
overwhelming this negative farming so
we're kind of trying to see if it has as
an end point and this is kind of a
simplified version of the results but
it's the same type of figure we saw
before cumulative soil c respired and
here we see we have our control again in
black but we have positive priming as
opposed to the last experiment where we
only had negative priming so when you
add the one milligram per gram
application rate we're actually
increasing the rate of soil organic
carbon mineralization but when we have
the higher application rates of five and
ten this is decreasing the
mineralization so it's important to note
that yes
char's is kind of causing negative
priming but it may not in all situations
and this is something we'll kind of have
to parse out in the future but maybe if
it's the mechanism like sorption those
sites are being used up there's no more
slice left to absorb the carbon so we
have positive framing and again this is
that same kind of figure taking away
each treatment from the controls to see
the magnitude of priming see the
positive standing over here the negative
here and again to speak to the substrate
switching mechanism which if we can all
recall is where the microbes are eating
the char instead of the soil this
basically the cumulation of the soil of
the char carbon respired would be would
describe that substrate switching and we
can see that the magnitude of this
respiration is nowhere near the
magnitude of our total negative priming
so we can really kind of cross off
substrate searching at this place and to
speak to toxicity this is kind of the
easiest way that I could think of to
kind of a say how microbes are doing
after being exposed to charge so this is
a fumigation extraction method of
microbial biomass so after I've
incubated my char in my soil for 40 days
I completed this assay and what this is
saying this is kind of a messy grass
with huge error bars is basically that
there's no significant differences in
microbial biomass communities if we're
adding charge or if pilum or if we're
not and this is looking at both the
topsoil and also a sub soil so a higher
carbon soil and a lower part as well so
you can kind of stage from this that
toxicity isn't really occurring which is
what this was saying over here and so
now we're going to move on to what we
have left so finally we're going to talk
about SSD sorption because that seems
most likely as a candidate for our
negative priming that we're seeing and a
really neat way to look at sorption is
just creating these adsorption isotherms
so I've taken different concentrations
of do see from the soil I use in my
incubation and I've shaken them
overnight with
different media so either a 200-degree
charge 450 degree char 752 creature or
these two soils and what you're seeing
here is over here we have desorption so
below the zero line all this DLC was
desorbed so we're seeing complete
resorption for this high temperature
with low temperature chart as well as
the topsoil and kind of the subsoil is
right in the middle and then for our
charge for our higher temperature charts
we have these or patients at lower
concentrations adsorption at higher
concentrations for the 450 degree char
which is the one I used in the
experiments I've talked about already
and we have complete pre almost complete
these absorption with a higher
temperature chart so as you increase the
temperature of pyrolysis we're having
more absorption another really exciting
way to look at adsorption institue is
nano SIM so I've labeled my charge very
highly with Delta 13 C and using this
amazing technique we're able to look at
the char and see what kind of carbon is
sticking to it so the char by itself so
this is one that's been uninvited so it
just has a super high delta 13 c value
which is indicated by this purple color
and this is a piece of char that's been
incubated with soil for 40 days and so
we can see that on the surface we have
these modeled colors we have a lot of
the slough natural abundance carbon so
what this is telling us is that over
time we are seeing adsorption of natural
abundance carbon on the surface of char
this can't tell us what exactly we're
looking at or why this is happening but
it's kind of a new neat way to be able
to look at sorption institue and
hopefully in the future this will be
kind of more quantitative science that
will be able to make more conclusive
more conclusions with so in conclusion
basically we've been able to cross off
or minimize a couple of these mechanisms
today and so and based on our results
we're thinking that SOC sorption is an
important mechanism we also have a lot
further to go with things
microbial signal sorption kind of
aggregation and we also know that this
is probably a combination of many
mechanisms as we've seen today we can
kind of compensate for part of this pie
but there's so much left and is all that
really coming from sorption maybe maybe
not we've basically ended the day with
more questions than we started with but
it is called research for a reason and
it's exciting to keep moving forward and
this mechanistic approach is just I
really love how really deeply scientific
it is it's just kind of probing at the
continuous details and being able to
build further from that and I've really
enjoyed this type of science and it
wouldn't be possible without my
committees so honis and janice and also
everyone in my lab who helped me out
especially our amazing research research
technicians and really everyone the
student hasn't done without my lab and
without all of you thank you
[Applause]
yeah so the soil I got it from Mount
Pleasant and kind of homogenized took
out all the rest rocks and roots and
dried it out saved it and then
completely dried it down and then I've
messed around I've done a lot of
iterations of the incubation or as like
pre-incubated the soil but for these
experiments today I mixed them with the
amendments dry and then added water
right before it started which i found
was just kind of the most types of Titus
way to keep everything keep everything
the same it's really hard when you're
like mixing mud and char together so
that's how they were treated before and
yes I have other experiments where have
added usually I'm adding an uncharged
version of the pile em so I am adding
biomass and in those were basically
seeing we are seeing negative priming
but it's mostly compensated for by this
substrate switching so you can see this
huge surge in the in the microbes eating
that that's like spicy exciting carbon
source and it's definitely different
mechanisms been with the charge any
other
the ones the five percent organic carbon
that sort of left so that was the way to
start with naturally yeah yes kind of a
tough yeah it's uh it's kind of like the
topsoil of yeah Mount Pleasant you have
four and a half five you can program
yeah at point five one two and a half
five and ten and on my figure I only
showed a couple of them because the
point five and the two and a half just
kind of mess like muddied it up but
essentially the points I've exerted
positive framing as well as the one as
you saw and the 2.5 exerted negative
priming but neither of those were
different enough from the control they
just kind of make it look a little messy
so what I was just going to be some
calculated in my head of what I mean
qualifying yes when acres of land so
yeah so I'm for the and so the for the
five milligrams per gram application
rate which is the one that we had that I
had on the figure so that would exert
kind of significantly different negative
priming and that translates to about
four tonnes per hectare four tonnes per
hectare yes no four tons per acre about
11 tonnes per hectare yes he did a lot
in
that would be yeah that would be a large
application so if you think about adding
compost a typical addition of compost is
about 10 tons per hectare 10 tons per
acre which is twice the amount of my
application rate but that has a similar
bulk density or even like much higher
higher than the char which is really
fluffy stuff so this would be like yeah
we would be adding a significant amount
of char but it's also confusing because
of the you know the depth of soil and
like that 8-inch plow where I don't it's
kind of really hard to translate it to
this but it would be like a significant
addition of char yeah it's not a
sprinkle yeah so you can away why cause
the mountain forms then over time I mean
that's kind of what this is saying but
we definitely need to look into that
more and break that down into especially
field experiments I mean this is in jars
in a lab so we need to accept this
further yes
we added oil
what well I don't think it should be
ruled out but I guess for me it wasn't
as exciting to look at so char has an
inherently like super high pH and a lot
of the soils I'm looking at our around
for so we know that's going to have a
huge effect to me we know that that's
probably I mean it's just kind of
something that we know what's happening
and that I didn't I just kind of wanted
to look at different mechanisms I wanted
to try to control for that and I know
it's super hard to control for that
because basically I'm adjusting the ph
with HD el Halim industrial ph of the
char which maybe isn't completely you
know compensating for the pH changes but
for me I was just kind of more
interested in other mechanisms that we
didn't know already had a profound
effect like we know pH is so important
like creation th and moisture arguably
like the most important factors but I
was kind of trying to probe beyond those
support
yeah it could very well be and that's
not something that I've looked at so in
the future
Oh
in fact we provide a little garden
pretty much what reduced at high ph oh I
don't know because I've only looked at
the system with these pH adjusted
situations but I mean I could it would
be pretty easy to do at these adsorption
isotherms with a nun pH adjusted charge
to see what happens because as we're
seeing in one of my first pieces of data
a lot of this negative priming is hat
can be happening very quickly so within
the scope of you know a 24 or 36 36 hour
adsorption experiment so I guess we'll
have to see I'm not sure how the change
in charge or pho
I
um we don't I mean we don't know it
could be i mean that's like adsorption
is something that could be happening
that quickly and it would probably
increase if you had a super high ph char
but that's not the mannequin feature yet
cuz i haven't tried it out there the
changing position without oh yeah i mean
they're definitely our changes sia my
kind of credit mr. did some work with
that kara in my lab is also working with
that that's not something that I've
looked at at all kind of avoided it but
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu